نعود للعاصمه البريطانيه لندن التي تشهد
اليوم تظاهره تحت شعار اوقفوا الاباده
الجماعيه في غزه يجوب هؤلاء المتظاهرون
شوارع العاصمه في مسيره تنتهي عند مقر
الحكومه حيث تقام التظاهر الكبرى التي
تنظمها جمعيات حقوقيه عده منها لجنه
التضامن مع فلسطين وتحالف اوقفوا الحرب
وقد وجه المنظمون انتقادات لشرطه العاصمه
بسبب ما يقولون انها
محاولات لترهيب المتظاهرين والتضييق
عليهم اسد الله الصاوي مراسل الجزيره انضم
الينا من لندن من وسط هذه التجمعات اسد
الله كيف تصف زخم هذه التجمعات والتظاهر
مقارنه مع تظاهرات
[موسيقى]
سابقه نعم جلال التظاهر هي في اولها بمعنى
ان المتظاهرين مازالوا يتجمعون الان سادع
المصور الزميل ناصر خان يريكم حجم التظاهر
وحجم الوجود الشرطي هنا في هذا المكان حتى
الان الشرطه تقدر اعداد المشاركين بعشرات
الالاف يتوقع ان ينضم اليهم المزيد من
المتظاهرين الذين يتكونون من مواطنين
مواطنين عاديين ومن نقابات متعدده
وتحالفات متعدده على راسها كما قلت انت
جمعيه التضامن مع فلسطين وتحالف اوقفوا
الحرب وجمعيه اصدقاء المسجد الاقصى يجب
الاشاره جلال الى ان هذه التظاهر تمثل
عوده الى التظاهرات الكبرى الحاشده
المتجمعه من مدن بريطانيا المختلفه هنا في
العاصمه البريطانيه لندن والتي تركز على
هتافات معينه وترفع لافتات معينه من
ابرزها اوقفوا الاباده الجماعيه في قطاع
غزه اوقفوا اطلاق النار الان وهناك
مطالبات ايضا بمحاسبه القاده الاسرائيليين
على ما يقول المتظاهرون انه اباده جماعيه
ترتكب من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع
غزه وهناك مطالبات بايقاف قصف اليمن وباي
القصف ايضا على سوريا والعراق يجب الاشاره
كما قلت جلال الى ان هذه تظاهره شهدت بعض
التوتر اثناء تنظيمها مع الشرطه الشرطه
فرضت قيودا اضافيا مثلا جميع الموجودين في
حي ويست منستر وسط لندن الذي تسير به هذه
التظاهر يمنع عليهم اليوم ارتداء اي اقنعه
للوجه سوى الخمار الاسلاميه مثلا اذا كان
لاسباب دينيه او اي غطاء للوجه اذا كان
لاسباب دينيه ولكن اي غطاء اخر للوجه هو
مرفوض بعض المتظاهرين سيما الذين لهم
اهالي في قطاع غزه كانوا يعني اعتادوا على
تغطيه وجوههم حتى لا يتم التنكيل باهالي
في قطاع غزه من من قبل القوات الاسرائيليه
والذين يعتبرون انها ترصد ما يحدث في
عواصم العالم المختلفه عموما هذه التظاهر
في بدايتها الان نتوقع ان تسير حتى مقر
الحكومه بقلب لندن مسافه على الاقل ثلاثه
اميال او اربعه كيلومترات او اكثر وهذه
التظاهر يتوقع ان تقف امام مقر الحكومه
وتوصل رسالتها الرئيسيه اوقفوا الاباده
الجماعيه اوقفوا اطلاق النار واوقف دعم
اسرائيل بالسلاح والمال ودعمها دبلوماسيا
اسعد الله كيف هي التفاعلات السياسيه في
المملكه المتحده مع هكذا
تحركات هناك جزء كبير من المجتمع
البريطاني مؤيد لهذا الحراك ولكن الحكومه
البريطانيه وحزب المحافظين الحاكم وايضا
حزب العمال حزب المعارضه الرئيسي كلهم
يؤيدون اسرائيل ويرفضون الدعوه الان الى
وقف اطلاق النار ولكن يجب الاشاره الى ان
وزير
الخارجيه ديفيد كاميرون اللورد ديفيد
كامرون قام مؤخرا بجوله في الشرق الاوسط
واظهر ما يبدو انه اختلافا في السياسه
البريطانيه ب حيث انه تحدث عن امكانيه
اعتراف بريطانيا بدوله فلسطينيه دون
انتظار نتائج محادثات سلام وايضا المح الى
انه يريد وقفا انسانيا فوريا لاطلاق النار
في قطاع غزه من اجل كما يقول ادخال
المساعدات واخراج من اسماهم عفوا من
اسماهم بالرهاب في من قطاع غزه
وا السماح بمفاوضات تفضي الى اطلاق نار
عفوا الى وقف دائم لاطلاق النار في قطاع
غزه كل هذا يشير الى وجود نوع من يعني
التحرك في المياه الراكده في السياسه
البريطانيه لعقود والتي يعني تدعم اسرائيل
بلا هواده وتؤيد الفلسطينيين ربما من
ناحيه ادخال مواد اغاثه او محاوله التوسط
ولكنها لم تبدي هذا التغير من قبل ولكن
هذه المظاهرات جلال لابد من الاشاره الى
ان الاعداد التي تخرج فيها كلما نظمت في
العاصمه لندن تكون كبيره للغايه وبانها
توصل رساله كبيره للسياسيين زعيم حزب
العمال المعارض مثلا كير سمر والذي يعتقد
كثيرون انه سيفوز في الانتخابات ال المقبل
وانه سيكون رئيس الحكومه المقبله في
بريطانيا بدا مؤخرا في التفكير بسبب
مقاطعه او اعلان جماعات مسلمه وعربيه
ومؤيده للحقوق الفلسطينيه نيتها مقاطعه
الانتخابات وهذا سيؤثر اساسا على فرصه حزب
العمال وعلى كير ارمر وعلى قدرته على
الفوز في الانتخابات المقبله كل هذا يشير
الى وجود نوع من المراجعه في الفكر
السياسي البريطاني
سيما من الحزب الذي يعتقد انه سيشكل
الحكومه المقبله الى اي مدى ستصل هذه
المراجعه غير معروف بعد ولكن ثمت شيء جديد
يحدث في السياسه البريطانيه نتيجه هذه
المظاهرات المؤيده والتي ترفع صوتها
بتاييد للحق الفلسطيني شكرا لك اسد الله
في
لندن